今天這個案例我覺得很有意思，Anthropic 的 Claude AI，我們以前都覺得它就是在數位世界裡面做做文字、寫寫程式，對不對？結果他們現在竟然讓 AI 自己去操控實驗室的儀器，自己做科學實驗。
等等，這個有點出乎意料，你是說 AI 不只是「思考」，還能「動手」了？這跟我們一般想像的 AI 差很遠。怎麼說呢，以前那些實驗室自動化設備不是早就有了嗎？有什麼特別的？
其實我一開始也有類似的疑問。原文裡面有提到，實驗室自動化技術存在幾十年了，但最大的痛點就是設備之間溝通困難，每個儀器都有自己的介面，要讓它們連起來，以前都需要花幾週甚至幾個月寫客製化的軟體。
所以問題就出在「溝通」上面？Anthropic 怎麼解決這個問題？這才是關鍵吧。
對，就是溝通。Anthropic 推出了一個「Model Hardware Standard」，他們說這個標準能讓不同設備之間有共同的語言，就像一個通用的「驅動程式」。只要設備能編程，透過這個驅動程式，就能讓 AI 代理程式了解並操作它，以前要花幾個月的工作，現在幾分鐘就能搞定。
幾分鐘？這數字有點誇張吧？這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，確實能大幅縮短時間。那這個共通語言具體是怎麼運作的？難道每個設備都能直接聽懂 AI 說的話？
他們的作法是簡化指令。原文說，這個標準會把指令簡化成像是「讀取」或「寫入」這種基本詞彙，不論是要檢查溫度還是設定操作時間，都用這種統一的簡單指令。這樣一來，所有設備都能用相同的語言交流，AI 就更容易學習如何使用不熟悉的設備。
嗯，聽起來有點像工業物聯網的概念，讓機器彼此能「對話」。如果我是創業者，特別是那種小型製造業或農業的老闆，這可能就很有用了。以前要自動化，光是設備整合就頭大，現在等於 AI 可以當那個整合的角色了。
沒錯，而且原文還提到，他們現在把這個系統作為「研究預覽」開放給一些實驗室和製造商試用。這表示他們也意識到這個技術在實際應用上的潛力。Anthropic 的科學家 Alek Kemeny 還分享了一個例子，Claude 自己操作顯微鏡找到了一個活體腦組織樣本中不熟悉的結構，連神經科學家都說：「對，就是那個。」
這點是真的厲害，AI 不只是按指令操作，還能像科學家一樣「探索」跟「調整」。不過，我還是有點懷疑，這種模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？如果 AI 還是會「幻覺」，在物理世界裡出錯了，那風險是不是很大？
你這個質疑很重要，原文也有提到這點。IBM 的首席研究科學家 Kaoutar El Maghraoui 就說：「這是個令人印象深刻的概念驗證，但我們如何確保物理世界的安全？因為小錯誤在這裡都可能造成大問題。」這也是為什麼 Anthropic 只先開放給少數夥伴，並承諾會一起建立安全評估機制。
聽起來他們也知道風險，所以才採取比較謹慎的策略。那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念能帶來什麼啟發？我們又不是做實驗室研究的。
我覺得可以這樣想，我們每天工作是不是也有很多流程是需要不同工具或軟體之間「溝通」的？比如資料匯入匯出、跨部門的協作。現在常常需要人為介入去「翻譯」或「手動串接」。
如果這個 AI 標準化溝通的概念能推廣，或許將來我們的工作中，AI 也能變成一個「統一介面」，讓我們各種軟體、設備能更順暢地協同作業，省去很多重複性的人工操作。
你這麼一說，好像也提醒了我們，AI 未來可能不只是螢幕前的助手，更可能是實際操作的「智能員工」，大幅提高效率並降低人力成本。